>>> THE THE MANHUNT FOR BRIAN
LAUNDRIE TAKING ON NEW URGENCY
WITH HIS FATHER JOINING SEARCH
CREWS FOR THE FIRST TIME AT THE
NATURE RESERVE IN FLORIDA.
IT COMES AS GABBY PETITO'S
MOTHER PLEADS WITH LAUNDRIE TO
TURN HIMSELF IN, SAYING SHE IS
GROWING MORE FRUSTRATED AS THE
DAYS GO ON.
LEYLA SANTIAGO IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: TODAY BRIAN
LAUNDRIE'S FATHER CHRIS LAUNDRIE
ASSISTING AUTHORITIES IN THE
SEARCH FOR HIS SON.
AFTER LEAVING HIS HOUSE ALONE
THIS MORNING, CHRIS IS SEEN
ENTERING THE CARLTON RESERVE
ALONG WITH THE POLICE.
THE ATTORNEY FOR THE FAMILY
TELLING CNN BRIAN'S FATHER SPENT
MORE THAN THREE HOURS AT THE
25,000 ACRE RESERVE, ASSISTING
AUTHORITIES IN THE SEARCH.
CHRIS WAS ASKED TO POINT OUT ANY
FAVORITE TRAILS OR SPOTS THAT
BRIAN MAY HAVE USED IN THE
PRESERVE, ALTHOUGH CHRIS AND
ROBERTA LAUNDRIE PROVIDED THIS
INFORMATION VERBALLY THREE WEEKS
AGO, IT IS NOW THOUGHT THAT
ONSITE ASSISTANCE MAY BE BETTER.
BRIAN REPORTEDLY TOLD HIS
PARENTS HE WAS HEADED TO THE
RESERVE WHEN THEY LAST SAW HIM
ON SEPTEMBER 13th.
MORE THAN THREE WEEKS LATER AND
STILL NO SIGN OF GABBY PETITO'S
FIANCE.
THE ATTORNEY FOR LAUNDRIE'S
PARENTS TELLING CNN BRIAN'S
PARENTS BELIEVE HE IS STILL
THERE, ADDING THE PARENTS SEE NO
REASON TO MAKE A PUBLIC CALL FOR
BRIAN TO SURRENDER TO
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE HE SAYS,
QUOTE, IN SHORT, THE PARENTS
BELIEVE BRIAN WAS AND STILL IS
IN THE PRESERVE.
SO THERE WAS NO REASON TO ISSUE
A PLEA ON MEDIA THAT HE, BRIAN,
DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS TO.
POLICE ARE NOW DENYING THAT A
RECENT CAMPSITE WAS FOUND AT THE
CARLTON RESERVE AFTER A SOURCE
CLOSE TO THE FAMILY REPORTED ONE
WEDNESDAY, HOLDING OFF CHRIS
LAUNDRIE FROM THE SEARCH FOR A
DAY WHILE POLICE INVESTIGATED.
NORTH PORT POLICE TELLING CNN,
QUOTE, IT POSSIBLE THEY THOUGHT
THERE MIGHT BE A CAMPSITE OUT
THERE OR SOMETHING THEY MAY HAVE
SEEN FROM THE AIR, BUT WHEN THEY
GOT ON THE GROUND, THAT'S NOT
WHAT IT TURNED OUT TO BE?
SURE, I THINK THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY.
BUT HE ALSO SAYS, QUOTE, BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT INVESTIGATORS ARE
TELLING ME THAT NO CAMPSITE WAS
FOUND OUT THERE.
MEANWHILE, GABBY PETITO'S
PARENTS AND STEPPARENTS GRIEVING
HER LOSS AND TELLING FOX NEWS
THEY HOPE BRIAN LAUNDRIE IS
FOUND ALIVE.
>> HE IS A MISSING PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> HE IS THE KEY TO THE PUZZLE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED OUT THERE.
YOU KNOW?
UNTIL THEY FIND HIM, WE WON'T
KNOW.
>> WE BELIEVE HE KNOWS
EVERYTHING.
>> AND ACCORDING TO THE ATTORNEY
FOR BRIAN'S PARENTS, THERE WERE
NO DISCOVERIES OUT THERE IN THAT
RESERVE TODAY.
HE TOLD US THAT CHRIS LAUNDRIE,
BRIAN'S FATHER, WAS OUT THERE TO
SHOW SEARCH TEAMS HIS FAVORITE
SPOTS OR PLACES WHERE BRIAN WAS
KNOWN TO FREQUENT.
AND THE ATTORNEY ADDED IN HIS
STATEMENT THAT THEY HOPE THEY
CAN FIND BRIAN.
ERIN?
>> ALL RIGHT, LEYLA, THANK YOU.
I WANT TO GO TO DAVE CANTERBURY.
HE IS A SURVIVAL EXPERT WHO
LIVED IN NORTH FLORIDA WHERE THE
SEARCH IS UNDER WAY.
CASEY JORDAN, A CRIMINOLOGIST
AND BEHAVIORAL ANALYST.
THANKS TO BOTH.
BRIAN'S PARENTS ARE CONVINCED HE
IS IN THIS NATURE PRESERVE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE BEEN SAYING
AND THEY WOULDN'T LOOK ANYWHERE
ELSE.
IF BRIAN HAS BEEN THERE FOR THE
PAST 25 DAYS, HOW LIKELY DO YOU
THINK IT IS THAT HE COULD STILL
BE ALIVE AND UNDETECTED TO THIS
POINT?
>> I THINK A LOT OF THAT DEPENDS
REALLY ON HOW PREPARED HE WAS
WHEN HE ENTERED THE AREA TO
BEGIN WITH.
IF HE HAD SUPPLIES AND A
BACKPACK, WHICH IT'S RUMORED
THAT HE HAD, HE HAD WAYS TO
DISINFECT WATER THROUGH
FILTRATION AND COVER TO PROTECT
HIMSELF FROM THE WEATHER AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, HE COULD
SURVIVE FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME.
BUT IF HE HAD WAYS TO GATHER
FOOD AND PROCESS THAT FOOD, HE
COULD SURVIVE EVEN LONGER.
THE QUESTION REALLY BECOMES IF
YOU CAN GATHER FOOD, HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO PROCESS AND COOK THAT
FOOD WITHOUT STARTING FIRE?
AND IF YOUR FILTRATION FAILS,
HOW YOU GOING TO DISINFECT THE
WATER WITHOUT FIRE?
STARTING FIRE IS GOING TO BE A
BIG NO-NO FOR HIM IF HE DOESN'T
WANT THE GET FOUND OR SEEN.
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO STAY OUT
THERE FOR A VERY LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
BUT I THINK UP TO THIS POINT, HE
COULD HAVE ENOUGH STUFF IN A
BACKPACK TO HAVE GOTTEN ALONG
THIS FAR AND STILL BE THERE.
>> THAT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
THING TO SAY.
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE 25 DAYS,
THEY WOULDN'T THINK THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU GIVE
THAT CONTEXT.
CASEY, BRIAN LAUNDRIE'S FATHER
WAS THERE AT THE NATURE RESERVE
FUTURE ABOUT THREE HOURS TODAY
WITH THE FBI IN THEIR SEARCH.
BRIAN LAUNDRIE FATHER SAYS HE
SHOWED THE FBI THE TRAILS, THE
PLACES BRIAN LIKED TO HIKE.
BUT HE SAYS THEY ALREADY GAVE
THIS INFORMATION TO THE FBI
THREE WEEKS AGO.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS IS ALL
ABOUT WITH BRIAN LAUNDRIE'S
FATHER NOW JOINING THEM HERE 25
DAYS LATER?
>> I DON'T THINK THIS WAS SO
MUCH ABOUT LOOKING FOR
CAMPSITES.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEY THINK
THAT BRIAN LAUNDRIE IS THERE OR
EVER WAS THERE.
I THINK THIS IS WHAT THEY CALL
AN OBSERVATIONAL TOUR.
IT WAS MORE ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OBSERVING CHRIS
LAUNDRIE, TALKING TO HIM, MAYBE
TRYING TO LOOSEN HIM UP, TRY TO
GAIN HIS TRUST, TRY TO GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE COOPERATION.
AND AS THEY WALK THROUGH THE
RESERVE, FIND OUT WHAT HE IS
CHATTING ABOUT, WHAT HE IS
TELLING THEM ABOUT HIS SON.
YOU KNOW, YOU REMEMBER TEN YEARS
AGO WITH CASEY ANTHONY, THEY DID
AN OBSERVATIONAL TOUR ALL THE
WAY INTO UNIVERSAL STUDIOS WHERE
SHE SAID SHE WORKED, EVEN THOUGH
THEY KNEW SHE DIDN'T WORK THERE,
BECAUSE THEY WERE TRYING TO FIND
OUT WHAT SHE WOULD DO AT THE END
OF THE GAME.
SO I THINK THIS WAS JUST AN
EXERCISE IN TRYING TO RULE OUT
THE RESERVE.
I DON'T THINK THEY'VE EVER
BELIEVED HE WAS REALLY THERE.
AT LEAST THEY RULED IT OUT TWO
OR THREE WEEKS AGO WHEN THERE
WAS NO SIGN OF HIM AT ALL.
>> THAT'S A FASCINATING POINT
THERE.
DAVE, GABBY PETITO'S FAMILY DID
AN INTERVIEW TODAY WHERE THEY
BELIEVE BRIAN LAUNDRIE IS ALIVE
AND THEY CITED HIS EXPERIENCE AS
AN OUTDOORSMAN.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I'M NOT CERTAIN, BUT I WOULD
THINK THAT HE IS IN AN AREA LIKE
THE APPALACHIAN TRAIL OR A
CAMPGROUND WHERE HE CAN LIVE OFF
THE LAND, BECAUSE HE HAD THOSE
SKILLS.
>> DO YOU THINK HE IS ALIVE?
DO YOU THINK HE IS IN THE
COUNTRY?
>> I DO BELIEVE HE IS A ALIVE.
COUNTRY, AGAIN, I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> DAVE, THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOW HE HAS EXPERIENCE HIKING THE
APPALACHIAN TRAIL.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, WITH THE
VAN LIFE THAT HE HAD BEEN LIVING
WITH GABBY, WE KNOW HE HAS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
EXPERIENCE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THAT REALLY
MEANS AND WHAT IT WOULD REALLY
REQUIRE.
SO WOULD ANY OF THIS REALLY
PREPARE HIM TO SURVIVE IN THE
WILD OR IN THAT FLORIDA NATURE
RESERVE?
>> I THINK IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE FLORIDA NATURE
PRESERVE, NOT NECESSARILY.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THAT
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
AS AN APPALACHIAN TRAIL HIKER.
YOU CAN ON THE APPALACHIAN TRAIL
WALK TWO OR THREE DAYS, BOUNCE
IN THROUGH A TOWN, RESUPPLY ANY
EQUIPMENT THAT YOU MAY NEED TO
REPLACE, GET FOOD THAT YOU MAY
NEED TO GET FOR THE NEXT TWO OR
THREE DAYS AND MOVE ON.
YOU CAN EVEN GET POSTAL DROPS OF
SUPPLIES AND FOOD.
HE IS NOT GOING TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY IF HE IS IN THAT
WILDLIFE AREA.
AND THAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR HIM BECAUSE HE
WILL HAVE TO FIND FOOD FROM THE
WILD SOONER OR LATER.
AND, AGAIN, 25 DAYS, PEOPLE GO
THAT LONG WITHOUT FOOD, AND IT'S
NOT A MAJOR HEALTH CONCERN.
BUT GOING MUCH LONGER THAN THAT
IS GOING TO BECOME A MAJOR
HEALTH CONCERN, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE WEATHER GETTING COLDER AND
HIS BODY CORE TEMPERATURE
ADJUSTING TO THAT AND BURNING
MORE CALORIES FASTER.
>> LAUNDRIE'S FAMILY SAYS HIS
PARENTS ARE, QUOTE, DISTRAUGHT
AND UPSET.
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU.
PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
WONDERING WHY THEY NEVER CAME
OUT AND -- THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
TEARFUL.
THEY'VE NEVER EXPRESSED THAT
CONCERN.
THEY'VE NEVER EXPRESSED LOVE FOR
HIS FIANCEE.
THEY'VE NEVER ASKED HELP TO FIND
HIM.
THE PARENTS BELIEVE BRIAN WAS
AND STILL IS IN THE RESERVE.
SO THERE WAS NO REASON TO ISSUE
A PLEA ON MEDIA THAT HE DOES NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO.
CASEY, DOES THAT EXPLANATION
MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU?
DOES IT MAKE THEIR SILENCE ANY
LESS SUSPICIOUS?
>> IT DOES NOT, AND FROM THE
GET-GO, I THINK AS WE RECREATE
EVERYTHING, WE ARE FIGURING OUT
THAT ALMOST EVERYTHING THEY SAY
AND DO AND THEIR ATTORNEY SAYS
AND DOES IS REALLY A RED
HERRING.
AND THIS CAMPGROUND DESOTO PARK
THAT THEY WENT TO ON THE 6th,
7th AND 8th, I AM BEGINNING TO
WONDER IF THAT WAS A DRY RUN
BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF LIKE A
SANDBAR PENINSULA WHERE A BOAT
MAY HAVE PICKED HIM UP AND
SCOOTED HIM OFF TO A CARIBBEAN
ISLAND.
THE MORE WE LISTEN TO THE
LAUNDRIE FAMILY, THE MORE
THEY'RE GETTING OVER ON THE
PUBLIC AND LAW ENFORCEMENT, I
THINK THEY NEED TO LOOK A LITTLE
MORE EXTERNALLY.
THEY'RE AFRAID HE MAY HAVE
HARMED HIMSELF.
I THINK THEY SAY THAT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW HE IS QUITE WELL AND
QUITE